[Música]
voy a pedir un favor a todos vamos a
empezar así
a quien de ustedes
quién de ustedes se acuerda de la
primera vez que fueron al cine
no me lo digan
vamos a hacerlo más bonito más román
cierre los ojos por favor cierre persona
tipo
quiero que recuerden la primer película
que viene
y bueno se acuerdan del nombre igual
segurísimo pero les puedo asegurar que
si se acuerda
el olor a las palomitas
eso ser gris y seguro se acuerdan
quieres hablar con ustedes
seguro que sonaba que había atrás sino
eso es un segurísimo lo recuerdas los
asientos
si estabas con tus papás los amigos más
en comiendo de las palomitas y
creo que la parte más fácil eran los
comentarios los que olían lo que sentías
lo que tocamos somos seres sensoriales
nosotros recordamos las cosas de acuerdo
a muchos sentidos nosotros
y ya para abrir los ojos cerrados lo ya
veremos
quiero pensar que es algo padre nuestro
recuerdo de cine te que son recuerdo
muchos lo recuerdo muy bonito
en mi caso el cine de mi barrio no olía
a palomitas o sea el suelo siempre
estaba pegajoso y la verdadera película
de terror saben cuál era ir al baño
no no no en serio en serio tu llegabas
al daño del cine de mi barrio y las
luces parpadeantes artistas y temas
y de repente pues madres se apagaban acá
imagínate ese error
de entrar a un baño que se apagaba la
luz abría la puerta y no sabía lo que te
vas a encontrar ya creando en un sitio
muy muy feo
pero aún así era mi lugar favorito en el
sitio en el que de verdad pasaba los
mejores momentos de mi infancia saben
por qué
porque en mi vida real pues la cosa no
estaba más bonita
yo crecí en uno de los barrios más
peligrosos de la ciudad en ella soy hijo
de una madre soltera orgulloso hijo de
una madre
estudió en una escuela pública como casi
todos los niños de mi barrio
y cuando terminaba de la escuela no me
iba a mi casa me iba al cine me iba al
cine porque
porque mi casa me espera mi padrastro
vieron que habrá un violento alcohólico
o maltratador no está más chingón ir al
cine
pero lo bueno es que gracias a este
amigo yo descubrí mi pasión y descubrí
mi vocación para los que no me conocen
yo me dedico al mundo del cine o
películas me dedico escribirlas médico a
producirlas médico al mundo del
entretenimiento entonces gracias a eso
descubrí mi pasión y descubrí mi
vocación lo cual está actual
y esto nos pasa todo el tiempo cuando
eres niño tus héroes sus ídolos todo lo
que tú ves en las películas normalmente
son jose imaginarme la película cada uno
se imaginó la película que cada uno vio
esto tiene su propio ídolo y en realidad
sus primeros ídolos son dos papas papá
es tu primer ídolo es tu primer
superhéroe ese superhéroe chingón al que
tuve si quieres imitar su ubicación
abierta
en mi caso mis héroes serán rock y eran
marty mcfly eran terminator era batman y
era superman
y porque nos gusta tanto porque somos
somos adictos a las historias nos gustan
los seres humanos siempre buscamos
patrones buscamos una guía para entender
lo que sucede en nuestra vida que ha
sido así somos somos seres que nos
encanta que nos cuenten historias por
eso estamos aquí nos encanta que alguien
nos lleve que nos haga ese viaje por eso
cuando empieza una película lo primero
que hacemos que creen que es buscar
quién es el protagonista
eso es lo primerito que hacemos el
protagonista es lo más importante porque
porque el protagonista es el que nos va
a llevar en ese viaje el protagonista es
el chingón es el que va a contar la
historia es el que va a ser el viaje y
una vez que tiene científica el
protagonista el protagonista tiene una
característica y esa es la primera que
tienen que saber el protagonista toma
decisiones
el protagonista actúa el protagonista es
proactivo no rap no reactivo el
protagonista así se lanza se lanza a la
aventura y eso en el mundo del cine le
llamamos el viaje
se los voy a explicar el viaje del euro
está muy chico tú tienes a un personaje
que está en su mundo ordinario como
todos nosotros tu día a día tienes tu
vida ordinaria y este personaje recibe
un llamado a la aventura
y que creen que pasa cuando recibes el
llamado a la aventura que se imaginan
qué pasa
porque los rechaza dices que no
luego tienes que aceptarlo si no no
habría película de película pero tiene
que haber ahí esa parte del conflicto
estás en tu mundo ordinario recibes el
llamado de la aventura y decides a
lanzar eso es lo primero en ese viaje
vamos a imaginarnos que este es el mundo
ordinario y este el mundo extraordinario
el mundo chingon donde está el objeto
del deseo del protagonismo y porque el
protagonista es el que tiene que hacer
todo el viaje y hace algo que en el cine
llamamos el arco dramático
y porque es un arco no se imagina es un
arco pero acostadito no así porque
porque lo agarras y lo estiras eso es un
arco entre más lo estiras es más grande
el arco el personaje que tiene el arco
más grande ese es el que evolucionó más
es el personaje que cambió más
imaginémonos algo que entendemos todos
star wars tenemos star wars no si no
bueno los más jóvenes entienden manda o
lori anne a luke skywalker es el que
sale al final de una temporada de que tu
papá empezó a hacer con ese es luke
skywalker bueno
luke skywalker empieza siendo un
granjero y el tipo acaba siendo el
piloto espacial que salva a la princesa
acaba haciendo igual es el que tuvo el
mayor arco es el que tuvo el mayor
crecimiento entonces hay que tener muy
claro quién es el protagonista es él
quien más cambio es el que más
evolucionó
cuando tú tienes ese personaje que ya
sabes que es el que evoluciona después
tiene una serie de pasos por ejemplo
tiene unos enemigos porque nada en esta
en esta vida en esta vieja te va a salir
a la primera cabrón las cosas se tienen
que poner complicadas sino cualquiera y
el viaje no sería el viaje del
héroe se tiene que poner difícil conocer
su mentor quienes tienes después unos
cuates que te van a ayudar
tienes consigues el elixir rescatar a la
princesa y logras las cosas y entonces
ya llegas al mundo extraordinario así
funciona esto tienes que hacer toda esa
evolución del personaje y porque nos
gusta tanto porque siempre queremos que
el personaje principal llegue el
superhéroe es el que nos atrae y parte
tanto nos gusta que lo que lo expresamos
a los demás por eso tú tienes la
camiseta de superman los calzones de
superman los calcetines superman los
condones de superman
todo es superman porque porque me amas
superman pero la vida real
tú no quieres ser superman
va a explicar
todo el mundo quiere romperle su madre a
supermedio todos hasta a batman quieren
madrear a superman
todo el mundo quiere romper a su madre
batman cabrones otro bueno way su mamá
santo callas carrón y le rompe su madre
de superman superman miren es parte
general de superman se llama la
fortaleza de la soledad domínguez quien
quiere vivir en la fortaleza de la
soledad
todos el superhéroe todos sus seres
queridos todos mueren
todos los superhéroes no pueden amar sus
decisiones las toman por los demás nunca
por ellos el superhéroe es completamente
reactivo es decir hay un incendio punta
y va superman hay una catástrofe de gas
oppermann pasa esto a esta web pues no
el superhéroes siempre tiene una cosa
que se llama marketing
y un arquetipo de quién sabe que son
arquetipos levanten la mano
mi mamá y mi hermana bueno pues no un
arquetipo es el prototipo de una imagen
ideal de algo
de lo que sea es la imagen perfecta de
algo esos son los arquetipos y nos
encanta seguir arquetipos y esto no es
nuevo esto viene de los griegos los
pinches griegos eran hermosos eran
guapos eran alguien es serán fuertes es
y eran los influencers
coronarse una imagen perfecta de quien
seguir eso eso lo hacían gares de los
griegos esos son los arquetipos
y la cosa es que nos encanta seguir
arquetipos y los arquetipos ya cambiaron
han evolucionado ayer qué tipos ahora a
qué tipos de villanos
y nos fascinan los villanos ahora mismo
si hubiera traído una camiseta de lo que
quede igual de chingón de los sopranos
la saga más importante que hay al día de
hoy de la industria del cine se llama
fast and furious son unos ladrones de
coches
pero no compres el arquetipo no lo
compres o sea ser un ladrón de
autopartes no te conviene te convierte
en dominic toretto que no es así y no o
sea yo sé que es más atractivo ser un
ladrón de la casa de papel que ser un
cirujano que le arregla el labio
leporino a unos niños es más chingón
pero tú no eres berlin tú no eres que el
zinc y como tú sí eres verdín
seguramente pero no eres que el zinc y
si no eres nairobi porque eso nos pasa a
que sí cuántos de ustedes de verdad
están pensadas en put cuál sería mi
nombre de la casa de papel
todas las ciudades ya están agarradas
yo sí sé cuál sería la mía
coatzacoalcos eso
además piénsenlo no piensen lo piensa en
la escena o sea tú estás viendo así de
han estado están aquí están todos dentro
vamos berlín tokio y los para allá y tú
recuerda que yo siempre te amado cual
sea cual cosa
en mí leo pina aquí hay un público que
si dice que yo debería de ser cual sea
cual cosa en casa de papel eso
pero los arquetipos se han cambiado los
arquetipos han evolucionado cuántas
veces has visto a batman yo les pregunto
a ustedes quién es batman
cada uno debe decir un actor distinto o
superman o sea el salto generacional que
hay
así que superman o sea un actor y no es
porque cada vez sea más joven deben como
spider-man cada vez es más chavito cada
vez es un niñito o sea las siguientes de
spider-man hacer una guardería acaban
del kinder de spider-man si son cada vez
más jóvenes porque porque ese es el
público
ese es el público al que vamos hay que
saber a quién le estamos hablando el
james bond de los ochentas no es el
mismo que del jameson de ahora el
arquetipo evolucionó
pero quieres ver que a lo mejor sí
el superman no existe ni batman tampoco
es así no existe wolverine no existe
iron man no existe un multimillonario
exótico que desarrolle tecnología para
cambiar el mundo si está en los modos
y bill gates
y diez besos pero vamos a ver si estos
tres huellas son los hombres más ricos
del mundo no pudieron salvar sus
matrimonios como chingo esperas que
váyanse a hablar el mundo cabrón no
nadie
nadie te va a venir a salvar nadie los
superiores no existen pero te encanta el
arquetipo el arquetipo nos mama y
queremos el arquetipo del choque porque
porque este invocan porque saben que los
superhéroes siempre sufren y tienen que
ganar siempre cabrón a huevo tienes que
ganar calor los villanos solo tienen que
ganar una vez
y los villanos se divierten y la
anatomía del villano ya no es solamente
con seres oscuros y cosas q legítimas
que les pasaron no ahora ya tienen las
razones reales
cuál es ser como son por eso enfatizamos
con ellos por eso te gusta que ganen los
villanos primero porque están súper
organizados ve o sea bien se le ven de
casa de papel de fast and furious
normales están súper coordinados claro
que quieren que ganen se llaman crimen
organizado o cabrón
o sea ni los políticos aquí se ponen de
acuerdo que habrán tienen un desmadre
entonces le es lógico que aunque estos
güeyes quieres que ganen son más
inteligentes lo hacen mejor
pero tú tampoco quiere hacer eso no
quiere ser un superhéroe plataforma de
ser un villano no quiere ser un
arquetipo
sabes por qué por qué no quieres ser la
historia de alguien más
quiere ser tu propia historia quieres
escribir una historia chingón tuya
nadie absolutamente nadie va a poder
dirigir esa película por
la película la dirige es tu escribes
y tú la protagonistas qué clase de
película quieres tener qué clase de
superhéroe quieres y yo les voy a decir
tres acciones súper poderosas para
escribir su propia historia
la primera
dirige con el ejemplo
conviértete en el padre que te hubiera
gustado obtener
conviértete en el líder que te hubiera
gustado seguir conviértete en la pareja
que tú quieres tener a tu lado
el respeto no se hereda respeto se gana
tienes que ser el jones no en la
batalla de los bastardos estar ahí al
frente de los puntazos no desde atrás
enseñando con el ejemplo eso es más
poderoso que cualquier discurso
segundo
puedes olvidar tus metas pero no tu
camino
tu camino es lo más importante que
tienes ahora mismo todos nosotros todos
absolutamente hemos pasado por la mayor
inseguridad de nuestras vidas es el
mayor momento de incertidumbre que ha
tenido la humanidad a nivel global
y qué es lo que tienes que hacer
adaptarte tienes que modificar te tienes
que adaptarte el imperio romano era
súper poderoso y cayó no porque no
fueran fuertes es porque no supieron
adaptarse tienes que estar dispuesto a
adaptarte a las situaciones todo el
mundo te dice es la nueva normalidad
pura madre esta es la normalidad si
sigue resistiendo te vas a ir mal
y tercero toda acción tiene una reacción
lo que hace es un pacto a los cerdos
siempre hay una llamado a la acción las
cosas no van a suceder por arte de magia
no van a suceder si tú las deseas y las
visualizas pura madre
tienes que levantarte y hacer las cosas
lo que realmente quieres todo el mundo
te habla de eso encuentra tu pasión
encuentra tu vocación y la chica va
primero te dice güey levántate temprano
has tu cama deja de tragar mal
ponte a hacer ejercicio haz las cosas
eso es lo que tienes que hacer eso es lo
que va a hacer que tú llegues hasta
donde tú quieras porque hay un lugar
donde cada uno de ustedes están es aquí
ese lugar es donde nadie puede llegar
ese es el lugar de tus sueños yo ahora
les digo ahora les pregunta a cada uno
de ustedes cuál es la historia que todos
ustedes van a contar
[Aplausos]